[Applause]
makers are very good when you attack
them from the wings
as james lines up a three ball you count
that
mike the question is how do you define
growth as a 19 year old in the nba
well you know what it's it's all about
the little things as lebron james just
continues
to knock down threes dort had made it
three earlier
not that time and i know ten games is
just a sample size
as lebron james lines up another three
ron hits two threes in a row this is his
last one is the defender trying to
decide whether to go
under the screen that is a lot of star
power just like there is tonight out on
the floor a lot of star power for this
young thunder team
lebron and he just got a little jab step
i mean he doesn't really need the jab
step because he's got
already the height advantage over dort
as the lakers clear it out on that left
side for lebron again
and this time he will take the three and
roby commits the foul that will be a
four point play possibility
for lebron with 21 points and a lot of
that is coming
from deep that is his fifth three
that's why you get to be called lbj